what's going on guys national master
james canty the third title tuesday
double the prizes guys let's get right
into it okay nothing else that needs to
be said
let's show you guys what we have here we
have title tuesday guys okay
it's gonna be actually a double the
prizes this week if you take a look at
that 3200
guys fun for this week look at that
that is absolutely amazing guys i hope
you guys are ready for that it's going
to be absolutely fun right
now uh the big boys are playing today in
this kind of format we have the 11 round
swiss
every tuesday 10 a.m pacific of course
and uh three minutes with one second
increment guys
payout is based off the chess.com tie
breaks now
let's get right into it the games have
started so no enough talking guys let's
get right into the games okay we got big
fellas like hikaru nakamura as we're
watching right now
3205. look at his rating he's not
playing
any games but he is playing a game but
at the same time he's not
3205 guys playing uh rondo
cop priscilloso from bolivia so let's
see what let's see what he's doing
actually
what's going on guys welcome to the
stream cool with knight comes to c4
immediately queen
is actually hitting a2 and i can come
out via the b3 square so maybe a4 but
that does weaken the b3 pawn
so maybe something like bishop a1 but he
plays bishop d4 instead guys
three minute one second increment here i
mean look how much time rondo's already
down here
hikaru just moves so fast guys it's
absolutely ridiculous sometimes
it's really absolutely ridiculous to be
honest but uh he's up like so much time
and he has that one second increment
here so he's almost not thinking
now this is attacked here he does have
some compensation on the file here this
is actually very annoying the a2
pawn is quite annoying uh we're k1
or a4 this does make it very weak so
let's see what he comes up with maybe
even something like e5 he actually takes
on f6 that was surprising
but he's actually going to hit him with
e5 as a follow-up
pretty nice look at the compensation
guys you always have to try to make it
as uh
as complicated as possible he carver
does a great job of doing that so
after uh bishop takes f6 and he i don't
know why he's thinking so long about
this one
you got to take with either either one
right pawn takes just messes up the
structure
bishop takes and allowed him to play e5
but he did take this way
and let him mess up the structure a4 is
now followed as well
this pawn is very weak it's hard to get
to it's defend it she would have to
attack this knight and
attack this pawn at the same time but
you only move
one move at a time so it may not work
here rick to d3 now we over protect it
maybe moving the knight back to c4 at
the same time
doubling the rooks on the weak d6 pawn
here as rondo
is down to 50 under a minute now about
50 seconds we do have that one second
increment which is very important
you can't just be flagged in one second
increment it can happen
but most times it doesn't happen it
doesn't happen in this one second
increment
and here we go hitting the d6 pawn now
you have to give uh
some props to rondo here playing really
strong honestly
he has uh you know played really good as
you see you got double rooks here like
he's making real legit threats against
here but it may not it just it just
doesn't seem like enough he plays rook
f3 hitting two separate pawns guys and
defending
all at the same time very very strong
stuff here knight takes d6 he actually
played king f1 instead
very interesting move very interesting
he didn't take the pawn guys
he just didn't take it maybe he'll take
it now
maybe not he doesn't take the pawn
h4 i guess he's just saying it's gonna
stay here but rookie six
can just defend it i wonder what he has
in mind
take it now
there we go okay oh my goodness there it
is takes
and takes perfect oh my goodness he hung
a rook that's it or he hang he hung the
exchange not a whole brook here
but this one's going to be a resignable
game there it is the resignation
and that game's over that game is
already over here guys as you take a
look at the standings here hikaru we got
misha nick
look at all the red here of course it is
title tuesday so you're only going to
see red
but you see all the gm's lined up here
gm gm gm
gm just like it's it's ridiculous how
strong these guys in here
fm sub josh my buddy josh is playing
iams in the chat i mean there's there's
a lot of people here guys
liam lee look at him playing this is
awesome
to see this live awesome to see it live
we do have more games of course let's go
to the next one here fair shape
fear chest on youtube and sketch cough
underscore v
looks like of course white's losing here
there's a resignation very quick that
one happened he's done
four he's done four let's go to operon
grandmaster o'byrne
what's going on usually when you get to
a position you have to see what
what everything looks like before you
actually say it was better first
okay well we have five pawns five pawns
two bishops this is a bishop pair versus
not having the bishop here
now he can remove the bishop here and he
does so but there is some checks and
some annoyance here
he plays knight d6 check instead and the
knight to ca game's over
instantly tactics win games oh my
goodness
get him off the board start a new one
that's not a move send the stretcher and
the rit knight takes b6 rook d7
and let's just have a nice day let's get
this off the screen this is a family
channel knight c5 is going to take on b3
we can just do it this way it probably
will take longer so let's just
take on h6 he could have kg7 rook h4
rook takes c6 is not a move because
knight d4 ouch
so he plays here with knight f6 as the
intention king to d3 hitting the knight
knight f6 anyway first might as well and
that's a wrap
start a new game hey what's up nmcanty
what's up oregon
big red welcome this is a family channel
luke star i mean come on now
come on come on now okay so
uh benjamin bach another strong
grandmaster guys you're gonna get
nothing but the best chest today we
definitely have a double the prizes
as well so i hope you guys are ready
double the prizes are here
you have to be titled are you titled you
could join you can still join you have
time
black one if you're a title player you
can um
you definitely can
you definitely can join let's
play another gm hey there big bro what's
up keith what's going on man how are you
bro good to see you
check this looks like a i don't know it
looks like a draw but expectively
honestly no objectively because these
pawns and you actually can uh
queen here so yeah this is a win because
you can queen we have the bishop
that we need to queen on this square so
it's not a draw
and look at this i mean look at this
beautiful play where does the knight go
have you ever seen a position like this
where the knight can't go anywhere
have to sacrifice it come around this
way the back way
and that's a wrap just like that i mean
decisive games everywhere guys this is
like
oh my goodness there are no draws today
nobody is taking draws today
this is strong chess today guys
how many players do we have in today's
tournament 634 players
wow yeah can and play absolutely nm's
can play cm's can play fm i am gm hi
canty
what's going on gold roof welcome to the
stream
let's go hey james speedy indian welcome
to the street
just be the indian check rookie six is
cool oh
maybe a draw no you can't do that he got
two seconds left three seconds king g3
oh oh don't repeat oh what you can't
really flag
yeah this is three one so i would i was
playing on for the flag but i forgot it
was three seconds and one second
so you can't not that you can't flag but
it's much harder to flag in this time
control
as you see guys the time keeps going up
they may think that you have no time
but in reality you actually have time
wow oh my goodness oh my goodness
get the man off the board send a
stretcher to his address he gonna need
one send him a call or something guys
well swindle of the year right here oh
my goodness how do you do that
well it's done it's because of time
trouble time trouble gets a song
that's not a move oh my goodness he
jumped
he definitely jumped the jedi what's up
gmc welcome to the stream
ouch that's here family show get it off
the board you're right speedy india my
bad let me get that off the board we got
kids watching here
that is nasty there push
oh we have a draw guys if pushing we
have the philidor position you're
keeping him on the third rank this is
the phillidor position
so if you can look it up if you don't
know about it you should know about it
this is how you draw a rook
in game keep the rook on the ring just
keep it back and forth back and forth
cool you can even trade it now and then
you walk the king up uh precisely
always straight back opposition get in
front of the pawn straight back
go up yep straight back in opposition
opposition
okay you could you could go right here
absolutely straight back
up and up again straight back and there
it is a draw guys a lot of you guys will
mess this up in the chat
so you have to make sure straight back
and opposition no matter which way he
goes
so if he goes this way opposition this
way if it goes this way opposition this
way if you're asking why can't he push
the pawn
well he can but then it's just a draw
now and there's no move for black
so that is draw 101 hopefully you guys
know how to do that
that would be great as round two should
be
starting soon should be starting here
look at all these ones here guys a lot
of ones and there it is round two is
just now picking up we're going to take
a look at a few games or
all of them as we can here we go hikaru
fan favorite we always want to watch
ikaru play right
always want to watch ikaru play i've
never lost a drawing game in game and i
never will that's to see
okay nice nice very nice attitude to
have there and statement
cast was out the way knight f6 so he
carved plays and this is a modern but
he he's a kings indian player as well
he's been playing a lot of modern
especially in blitz chess
and he's very excellent with these
setups guys a lot of times you remove
the knight
you play f5 and f4 and then you play h6
and g5 do something with the bishop and
you actually pawn storm
uh he has some very great games in in
this in this manner there it is knight
to d7
followed by f5 and f4 guys he's gonna
pawn storm
very quickly and as you know he carbo
plays really fast he's 3205
that's an understatement he should be
higher right and then three minutes in
one second increment
on this guys so let's see what happens
knight to d7 more in a king's indian
fashion from a modern defeat
from a modern defense it's almost like
he's playing sort of
king's indian against everything king's
indian for life and c3 cecil
c3 sicilian for the kill it's actually
c3 cecilia you drop the iliad
drop the alien sicilian drop the alien
that's right c3 still for the kill
speedy indian absolutely
that's our favorite opening pawn takes
and rook takes ca5
he plays knight c5 instead because this
pawn like we're always going to get this
he doesn't worry about it at all
e4 is hanging and not really it's just
attacked but not hanging
f5 was played guys and white's doing a
great job of kind of restricting
a little bit you may see something like
queen e8 eventually maybe even h6 well
h6 doesn't work we just take it
but you do have to watch out for this
too as well i'm sure carl sees that
there are no immediate night jumps
besides knight b5 it doesn't do much
if you could do something in the center
that would be great but unfortunately
it's blocked
so you can't do anything there as his
time winds down
hit carlos plays fast he's really strong
what's up gizmeister welcome to the
stream
you know so uh with the big boy chester
guys we're gonna stick on this game here
to see what happens rick takes a5
is the last move his wife tries to
figure out what to do and even after
knight b5 i think it just hangs upon
here rick takes a4
and we're good to go bishop to h5
on the board
three minutes one second increment so
this was interesting let's go back and
see that again takes takes bishop h5
that's an interesting move i wonder what
the intention is for this
um i don't really know oh queen eight
okay he's just stopping my queen eight
move that's
that's just he thought about that one
like he really thought about that one
that's pretty good mr page five stopping
queen eight because that was the movie
wanted to make so you may have to settle
with queen to d7 now
today's a break from us qualifier yes
yes
thank you guys in the chat bishop f6 now
trying to get rid of this bishop we're
probably gonna or we are going to take
on f6 he plays bishop h6 and now we have
the rook
on the file here but now it's not the
type of attack that we thought we would
be getting
as black here or the attack that we
wanted to have
maybe we could play f4 and allow him to
take so that this rook will have access
to this rank now
due to the fact that we capture on c5
it's forced by the way the bishop is
trapped it does give us a square for the
knight to go to as well they can even
swing into h4 and g2
you also have moves like queen f8 queen
g7 just to be a little bit annoying here
he plays knight g6 did not expect this
one at
all actually knight to g6 well now
knight h4
is still annoying he plays knight to d7
instead these are very hard to predict
the moves with hikaru of course and
car which is like different plans like
what is this even doing 1957 he moves
out of the way
we're going to see in a minute or so
though e4 maybe 95.
light square bishop gets to e6 are you
talking about this way
could be annoying maybe he's trying to
stop that maybe
for now
let's stop by say thank you for teaching
them how to throw
so uh nice that's what's up
i think that's what knight g6 is for
yeah bishop g5
it's a good move actually that's a
really good move for knight f4
i'm assuming what's this move doing uh
revealing
here but he's down on time guys you have
to pay attention like we was using
we were saying this a lot in the us
champs online qualifier you have to use
the clock as a piece
you have to use the clock as a piece so
instead of having 16 pieces when you set
up
all your pawns and your pieces all
together 16 pieces you need to add one
and one more
which is the clock and here 42 seconds
here is not going to cut it against
hikaru nakamura
i mean this position may even be you
know like
slightly equal maybe slightly better for
black of course especially with the rook
file and stuff like that
but with not enough time it doesn't
matter does not matter
love your commentary really helps to get
my mind into the masterminds thank you
wonder puppy
welcome to the stream hope you're doing
well title tuesday guys doubled the
prices here and the big boys
are playing today we have ikaru nakamura
and many other gm's guys many other gm's
so
look out and don't go anywhere knight to
d4
wait what just happened he just went
back to d4
yeah that my mind is right i was like
did he just hang a piece but
what is the i the idea bro wow
i guess pawn takes you're hitting this
pawn you're hitting the knight
so if pawn takes knight yeah he took on
a5
he didn't take the piece that must have
been strong nicey what is going on right
now
the this is pinned but you can't take
this
so he takes here so he lost in exchange
but he's getting it right back with
interest
geez tactics win games oh my goodness e4
knight takes you getting mated in a few
it feels like you're getting mated in a
few knight f3 doesn't work you do have
knight d2
that's a great move guys knight d2 is
really cool knight d2
knight f3 anyway he plays knight to c3
directly hitting the queen
so knight f3 is check anyway because we
have the protection
with our queen here and 10 seconds for
fahad here very strong though he's
international master here from
bangladesh how important is it to
coordinate your knight one thousand
percent
important uh it depends on what piece
you're using maybe you're using the
bishop with it oh my goodness this oh
man oh this hurts oh man
yikes just combo after combo come on can
we have some mercy on some of these
players hikaru
okay operon is playing black here it
looks like he's in trouble though king
g6 rook h8
rook h rook h8 is mate this is the
and you can even go this way either way
yikes yeah black is definitely lost here
no way around this it's good to know the
coordination of the pieces it usually
takes three
or more pieces for a successful attack
beating a strong i am getting one elo
yeah
that's the life of ikaru right you know
yeah i just beat a 2900 got two points
you know
three points absolutely insane another
level
half man half everything else bishop f6
rook h
8 is going to be mate if king f7 then
there's rook h7 followed by king g or e6
if think of king e8 you would want to go
king e6
to cut off the king d7 escape square
here but 10 seconds for
mom chill petkov but it's actually
he's not going to flag this is three
minutes to one second increment
reagan qc thanks for the sub eight
months
eight months says let's have some good
chess that's right today
definitely going to be excellent chess
rick takes d5 and king to g6 should be
game over start a new game big fella
start a new game it doesn't matter i'll
take with the bishop doesn't matter what
you do
i go right back and rook h8 and there it
is resignation
g g great game great
game let's take a look at the standings
here
take a look at standings twos and carl
at one point it started turning like
32.05
got one point out of that
fair chess on youtube is three thousand
as well we got a couple of three
thousands in here
liam lay vincent kymer very strong
strong gm young look at all these
players guys i mean this is the best
kind of chess you get to see here you
know
it's exciting let's go on to this next
game some other gm
is playing a strong national master here
g4 he's playing good honestly looks like
a draw
he has to be careful bishop d1 knight f6
it looks like a draw the idea is to
as soon as i can trade off this pawn if
i'm able to
no you can't lose both h5 should be good
now
yeah h5 would have gave him probably a
little bit of hope
if i could trade off one pawn i'm going
to sack my bishop for the other that's
the idea here
max what's up max max milne in the chat
here's his h5 move did she oh i was
about to did he flag
you can't be doing that don't scare
yourself like that
you do have that one second increment
there should be no reason to be flagging
here
what is he doing time trouble getting
him now he didn't lost the pawn
yeah x bishop e8 i guess
yeah this is losing let's see the
technique guys now you should be able to
push both of these
he missed he definitely messed this up
he could have had a chance
for a draw i think but now
these pawns are mobile and going crazy
he goes he has to stay on this diagonal
for any type of hope
yikes yeah that's a wrap that's over
bishop
three king takes he was going for one
last little trick
and there it is game's over yikes
time trouble though time trouble got him
that's exactly what happened guys
as round three is about to start round
three starts in a few
thanks for the sub appreciate it
okay let's go to the next game guys
hikaru and chess lover both have two
points here we go hikar will show us
something nice here
flexibility and knight f3 we don't know
what he's going to play yet
and then he plays his usual stuff
honestly b3
usually sometimes he'll play it first
this is the larson system guys
and it's an offbeat opening that throws
people off and
it's also an attacking opening as weird
as it is as weird as it may look
it's also a very it's an attacking
opening so
kind of weird let's see how he attacks
here bishop e2 bishop to b2 you play c4
i'm an e4 for life kind of guy but at
the same time um
it's very nice to see this did he just
hang upon he does have knight no he
doesn't yeah he's hung upon
hanging upon against his cargo is not
going to get you anywhere this could be
over already
what's the best way to start chess as a
beginner well one of the it's like you
know a few steps number one is
definitely play
you have to play you have to keep
playing and the reason why you have to
play is get the experience
but what's good what's not you know what
do you like what don't you like you know
what positions
are you getting and you start catering
it to positions you like
and start learning openings and um and
uh
games and players that play like you
lightsabers on let's write masculine and
another thing to do um
for as a beginner is to study
study all parts of your game opening
middle tactics tactics being
big events big emphasis on tactics
is that not a zucker tour no it was not
observatory it was close though
very close but this is a ready nimso
larson
already nemzo larsen here
not a big fan of these positions myself
i am e4 for life i love attacking chess
not not that you can't get attacking
chess from here but i'm just more
familiar with those positions and
bobby fischer you know a lot of stuff
like just e4 for life hey big fella oh
mid what's up man and hakeem what's
going on guys
bishop to f3 after bishop takes f3
knight takes f3 here
let's just see the technique that hikaru
uses in this game to see what happens
this pawn
runs down here to create some weaknesses
but it's actually very
solid with the pawn defending the queen
defending the rook is defended
so this is not even anything to worry
about that's why the bishop is on c3 as
well
a3 doesn't really matter for us it's
also actually a weakness
so honestly his best bet will be trading
these off because this could become a
weakness
if he's not careful
queen to e4 interesting move pretty good
i like it
i like queen e4 guys queenie 4 is kind
of annoying
it's forcing an issue in a way maybe
queen c1 that's passive
queen takes c4 plays queen e2 this out
of the way no queen trade because it
feels like black has a slight initiative
they get a strong knight on e4
still have the file here some pressure
on the a file
not a smart trade so he plays queen e2
c5 to kind of lock the position down a
little bit and we do have a trade
we could take this he says no don't want
to double the pawns mess up the
structure so let's just go rook d1
get him off the board
get him off the boy here he goes back
rook a8 yeah he's playing really strong
chess lover 108
international master here from zybarian
all right by yen i forgot i said but
yeah he's uh
very strong international master playing
pretty good to be honest i mean this is
not a
dominant game that you usually would see
from nakamura
not dominant but we do prefer white they
do have a very strong file i love this
knight now
f3 is not a move guys by the way e3 is
hanging it feels like the queen's trap
but it's not
very interesting move i think the idea
guys is this knight d7
followed by knight f6 which make for
something like knight h5 or knight to e8
making the knight very very weird
looking
yeah he's in the think tank and there it
is knight h5 guys 95 is on the board we
would love to kick it it's called
removing the defender that would be h3
and g4
that's going to take some time though i
don't think this could realistically
work he might be going for it okay
okay karu okay yeah he's listening no
i'm actually just
feeling good that he made the move that
i thought h3 and g4 and the knight has
to move somewhere but maybe knight d7
first because knight f6 is a possibility
right now so you would want to play
something like knight to d7
a3 makes sense we could just go queen to
c3 bring the queen a little bit closer
into the game
queen a1 is ridiculous but it can be
played but queen c3 keeps the same
the same um same threat there it is
queen to c3 on the board
thanks wonder probably appreciate it
appreciate you there
okay thanks
appreciate it also follow the big fella
thanks max
thanks we missed a few moves here let's
go back queen c3 knight f6
and f3 queen f5 so i'm wondering
maybe e4 just makes another hole so
maybe no e4 so he actually moves knight
back to d3
instead appreciate it sub casey what's
up omni your commentary is easy for a
newbie like me to understand thanks for
your effort i'm loving
loving the love here appreciate it
absolutely glad i can help if
anything let me know we in here rook to
d8
and rick to d2 i'm telling you guys this
guy is playing really strong against
just feels like he icarus more space
again like we talked about right this
pawn being a weakness
so if we trade as hikaru here if we go
through trades
now movie the night may be scary because
queen b1 check and
maybe like this pawn could be a little
weak ourselves here so you got to be
careful
but uh white's playing black's playing
pretty good
black's playing a pretty good game he's
not been crushed by hikaru
izar azerbaijan azer
bai shan thank you because i always get
that wrong
i literally always get it wrong and
these are by chan
appreciate it we in here that's right we
can hear gizmeister can you have two i
actually saw this
i just didn't think he would actually
play this i thought i thought he would
find something better
but can you have two didn't make sense
here but now yeah this is annoying
so i guess maybe it was a good move but
now this is annoying here and we are
going for trades now
we can remove it the queen doesn't have
access here anymore that check is very
scary oh my goodness i gotta go king e2
and king d1
kg1 drops a knight king f1 you jumping
off the dpm basically i mean this feels
like this knight is game over but he
went forward anyway
knight to g3 says that after knight to
g3 and i go king to g1
find a move big fella that's what he
says find a move i
am hikaru nakamura and he stood up and
flexed real hard
night yeah king g1 and moved out of the
way king f1 king g1
knight here pushing e4 put it keeping
the clock on him right now keeping the
clock on him
he has one second increment he's living
off the increment knight to d5 should
win or close
close and sacrifice on d4 he plays rick
d1 instead
because that was a check now we could
sack it anyway he says no sacking
i don't need to sack it i'm just going
to put the queen on f2 knight takes f3
is a pawn
he missed it no it's not queen takes f3
actually knight g4
e5 now queen h4 same intention queen d8
knight h6 is there any win is there a
win anywhere
anywhere nope nothing yet so he just
takes it
look at this man surviving off this
increment surviving off the
increment right now this is amazing
surviving could you cover gm vincent
keimer later
yes we would love to thanks again for
listening i've increased my rating 400
points pushing 1700 let's go quantum
knights
let's go quantum knights with the big
boy rating
getting up there now kicaro is actually
lower on time too but
uh he is definitely he's he car was not
living off the increment i mean this is
where
he thrives in this time control here
guys rook to e3 knight check
move the king up not to get forked with
the knight here we go
knight to e3 maybe knight to d5 is an
attention takes takes maybe rookie 5
there it is hitting g5 guys
idea maybe even to play work at 5. take
on g5 the knights hanging
knight d5 is coming knight t5 is coming
here it is check
maybe take on b6 this is definitely
winning for white now
definitely winning for white now oh
that's a wrap start a new game
he finds it time trouble gets us all and
hikaru nakamura does it again
or what else did you think he was gonna
do what else
this is what this man does the carbon
nakamura in first place
there's a lot of threes to be honest
actually there's actually um i can't
actually
count all of them but there are there's
a good number of threes guys
good number of threes three and oh
that's not a move says omni that's right
yep good number three's here let's move
on to another game though
um is vincent still playing are we able
to catch vincent keimer
if we see him we will check him out
lawrence trent is playing cool
too easy says quantum knights too easy
this is interesting oh he dropped his
rook oh my goodness that hurts
yikes just dropped the whole thing
it's gone it's gone hikaru is not a
human being you know he's half man
and then half blank and the blank is
like
whatever you feel that with whatever you
feel that
let's go over to uh oh last game last
game here should be ending in a few
seconds here and looks like a draw this
would definitely be a draw king h5
is a draw b4 yeah b4 is a draw too
either he's going to take it or i'm good
he's going to let me queen or whatever
right there's draw guys that's round
number three nice job
nice job these guys are going at it
going at it
we'll wait for round three here guys and
it started oh this is a big game right
here guys pay attention to this i mean
we won't leave this game at all alexis
sheroff
sure i've got they there's variations
named after shiroff
okay so alexis sheroff versus hikaru
nakamura
this is a sight to see so don't take
your eyes off the screen if you don't
know alexis share off you can just
google him to be honest
and you'll find a lot of fun stuff
actually
um yeah went to uh it had some lessons
in
like was the same place from tao
basically they're from the same place
and stuff like that
it's like awesome shirt off nakamura bro
let's go okay but first off we have this
roy lopez but then it's a finchetto
defense and i am not familiar i mean
after i left
i played a scotch gambit now and like
the vienna sometimes but
um i'm usually always uh like
i'm when i played the roy lopez i never
played the bishop g7 and i've never
faced it so this is a world i am not
familiar with
with black but you know knocking
nakamura been finchetto in like every
every game with black he's been
finchetto in that bishop
every game
every single game he's been like that
okay let's move this back over here
amazing right yep so let if we look at
the uh the dynamicism of the game what's
really going on right now first off
anytime you assess a position guys i
want you to really pay attention to this
anytime you come into a position you
start with the pawns just to assess to
see what's going on
are the pawns the same do they have the
same amount what is it what is it right
so
six pawns to six pawns except white has
an isolated pawn
so that's a big difference and as you
see hikaru already recognizes that and
the square in front of the pawn is
always just the most important square
especially
when you're dealing with an isolated
pawn so you blockade the square
you trade the pieces to defend it maybe
the queen not this one because that
would bring this pawn
closer to defend so that would be no
good so you want to make trades here h6
is probably incoming
something like maybe queen d6 and rook
d8 but we're going to bully this pawn
and if we win this pawn
the game could be virtually over and we
have a target for the rest of the game
so this is really easy for um
for hikaru to play because he is playing
when i see the pawn now
if i am playing with the isolated pawn
as white here
the problem is or the problem is the
isolated pawn the second thing is i
actually have to play dynamically
with shiroff has no problem playing
dynamically
he has a g4 variation in almost every
every opening the shirt off g4 you know
he always likes to launch g4
so with that being said we know sheriff
is going to come up with something here
and try to limit
the trades that he makes because he'd
know he has an isolated pawn
good content thanks nicolus nikolas
you turned me on to the scotch gambit
and i finished people in five moves see
hey man look you know we don't like to
brag but we do know our scotch gambino
how long do these tournaments last 11
rounds we're in round uh four right now
run four right now 11 rounds three
minutes one second increment guys
last move was rook a to c1 and queen to
d6 as you see we said we were going to
do this anyway
and probably maybe moving the rook at
the f rook now this knight on e5 is a
monster here so he's actually
not only you know doing that but he's
freeing up the knight to be able to take
on e4
or play something like knight to d7 rook
to d1 would almost be a blunder almost
of course
bishop g4 is looming looming it's not
there because knight takes g4
but there is some variations that could
happen where uh that could be available
knight to d7 seems like that's incoming
here sheriff was up more time here but
now of course when you're playing
cardboard hikaru was not down on time
like at all now he's uh
he's um down a little bit on time it's
kind of going back and forth here but he
has a
a super tough opponent used to study
with tao from the same city
as tao guys so this man is
amazing so eval bar actually let me turn
that on for you but i have to fix
something
there we go it should work
there we go there's the eval bar gotcha
what's up rockas what's going on man
you always get caught with the bishop
takes f7 queen h5 trick
that does happen yeah there's the eval
bar for you neil fire on a boar versus
eyes on the ceiling right
i mean right come on now come on eval
bar saying it's about equal here
let's actually see what's really going
on
knight to b4 hey carl what's he
threatening he's really threatening a2
i know he thought a3 oh that lost on the
spot i mean on the spot that was a
terrible move
engine's like get out of here trust game
with the six months
let's go yeah i guess that was it queen
takes d4 start a new game you dropping
everything
knight takes c6 that's not a move
knight takes c6 and we can start a new
one big fella not today
yeah we know you shiroff but not today
basically is what
not gorf is saying nakamura is saying
because this is uh this is over
resignation gg yikes
yeah i think he just blundered here
can't you just play a3
what was he scared of oh i guess just
taking anyway
that was a strong move bro the car route
is just another level bro
man this was nice it was fun to see this
takes takes
bishop h4 stepping out of the way of f6
and the knight before dang that pawn was
hanging and you see what happened
he lost the the moment after the
isolated pawn
was captured he lost guys okay it's very
very important right
what did we talk about the entire game
was this pawn
and as soon as he took it the game was
over be aware
and play it pay attention to the
isolated pawns
we have liam lay i always just say that
because like liam lay q
or q liam lay but liam lee william lee
very strong player of course
as we know guys he is from vietnam
but this position doesn't look that
strong i'm just going to be honest just
staring at it just like quick glance
look over look away like what happened
there's two knights here
the king side is absolutely ridiculous
there's so many holes over here
one two three four pieces are close by
the king in attacking situations you
will count the pawn as a piece
even though it's a pawn but usually you
just call it a pawn but of course in
attacking situations you will count this
as one of the pieces you used to attack
here
pawn takes knight uh this is intro oh
yikes okay
okay it feels like it feels like
everything is hanging it feels like he's
getting mated
it says mate in three and just says mate
in three oh here it is kg1 knight h3 oh
my goodness
oh whoa don't even do it to him like
that
why do you do it to him like that wow
amazing
amazing recommendations best way to
learn theory um you can start with
watching grand master games in games
that you like
or openings that you like even classics
and then
you can start finding opening books use
chess.com
of course they have the openings tool
the opening explorer
which helps you a lot so you do want to
use the chest.com tool on that highly
recommend it
chess warrior
yeah white's just crushing right
he's oh he's playing on because this is
kind of like one of those i'm mad kind
of games
because the gm is losing he's and he's
like up 100 points basically
he's just kind of mad here so he's just
gonna play on it does happen though
it does happen knight takes g2
yes this is game over guys but he's just
gonna play on now queening
if you queen rick takes g2
if you queen his rook takes g2 he was
trying to get him in a stalemate trick
that would have been amazing c360 for
the kill king what's up matt dub
welcome thank you so much
how is this how are you making this so
hard for yourself okay
i was like why is this so hard why is he
like why is this so difficult for him
right now there it is
okay you figured it out we figured it
out there
still got more games left let's check
out this next one parked in
easy one guys easy one very easy of
course for people that don't know how to
you know mate with king and queen just
pay attention here just pay attention
never thought queen's gamut series would
force me to play chess
let's go yeah you playing chess now
excellent if you are from the queen's
gambit series
much love to you make sure you get on
chess.com upgrade your account to
premium
and start using the tools and get right
get right
okay that game's over fair play fair
chess play
what is his name fair chess on youtube
okay fair chess on youtube
this is a hard one oh queen x
you could have won queen h6 but i guess
oh he's just trying to snap the pawns
because they're annoying
right snap all the pawns first i would
just take the pawn take the punt there
we go
take the pawn and don't worry about now
now you can go to work on the technique
now
it even have the extra pawn that even
helps even more usually king and queen
versus king rick it is a win it's just a
lot of technicalities to it
but here now it's a lot easier because
you have this extra pawn
so i mean everything wins here he has a
check uh he could have taken queen takes
h7
king g7 doesn't matter there's a queen
gg
g g games over there
let's go over here to this one games are
ending guys games are ending
games are ending that all of them
let's just see
let's see guys
cool all the games are finished
excellent all right guys so let's take a
look at cool real quick at the standings
this is what the sandies look like after
four rounds we got a few fours some
threes and things like that guys but
we will return very soon guys we're
gonna take a quick break
fair play check guys and we'll see you
guys very soon don't go anywhere
don't go anywhere this is title tuesday
double the prizes guys
and we'll see you as soon as we get back
[Music]
so
and we're back guys and we are we are
back let's go let's go okay round five
has started let's get right into the
games okay here we go
ikaro versus angry twin this is
international master out of russia
nice russia they're born actually uh
2100 over there or always born like 2100
over there
where is actually
kind of weird different link
there it is actually
found it here we go guys it's like what
here we go
angry twins right here what's the time
three minutes one second increment guys
yeah they like boring 2100 over there
right so all right let's actually
uh go back though and see what happens
so we got back here
and what what was this opening oh semi
semi slob
okay send me some look at that g4
aggressive using shiroff's tactics in a
way
g4 okay so we got this far into the game
and honestly oh i like this attack by
white
knight g5 my my goodness like
this man hikaru is a monster look at
this pawn takes now you're in trouble in
a way
bishop v4 would be beautiful we would
love to do this but of course we can't
because of the pawn here but this was
mate so he had to cover mate so he
played queen to g6
also his queen was hanging so queen g6
was forced we would love to play bishop
before of course once again
he might be thinking about this move and
actually sacrificing the pawn
maybe sacrificing too much maybe a
little bit too much but we will see
in place queen a4 just gets out of the
way queen takes b4 is a possibility
you have to ask is he really going to
take this pawn though the king is here
it's very weak on c1
and the rook to c8 does happen at the
right moment he could be in a lot of
trouble guys
a lot of trouble could it could happen
for him
a lot of trouble b5 happened
pawn takes yeah again this c file is
very weak
but he has a weak h file so it's kind of
the same
yo thanks williams appreciate you
thank you thank you okay cool so what's
going on queen to d3
so he dig it out of the way a little bit
king b1 is going to be played eventually
let's see if we have anything in the
meantime can we get f4 to work he plays
f3 instead bishop h4 is the intention
with some trouble after bishop e7
very very careful with your life here
very very careful
cool got it perfect
blue background you like the blue thanks
banana
all right so white's definitely doing
great here as we as you see the bishops
are going to swipe this board
the question is how do we get in here so
maybe like rick g1
reason for that i want to play rook h6
and double but as soon as you move the
rook he's just gonna take this one
so you may need to move this one first
so you can be allowed to play something
like work h6
maybe it's not called for though it
might be too aggressive that's my
problem
my problem which is a good problem to
have is that you know i'm too aggressive
sometimes my favorite player is tal
i have the game my life and games of
town so i'm always thinking about
how does how would he play it he would
destroy you like this time and
experience to know the positions you can
do that in
but uh yeah definitely trying to get
something to work on this h file here
now we have to trade and like it gets
kind of annoying but this will be a
technical win
here and and he car was very good at the
technical wins where you have to really
kind of grind it out
use the advantage and even abandon what
you thought was the best
he abandoned what he what looked great
right and now he's just
a completely different system moves the
bishop around me carl is an expert or
mastery wizard a grand mastery
everything else
at this technique here just being able
to switch and do something else
and and doing the unexpected very very
strong
very very strong chess
oh thank you appreciate that jj the
ultra appreciate it man i'm loving it
myself
loving it there was a check here bishop
before looking good
queen c5 i think's a little bit better
maybe get the queen a little bit more
active because it's not doing much over
here so he goes back
instead says kick the bishop maybe e4
actually that hangs upon
so he plays rick c5 keeping the threats
up it's always good to keep threats
alive guys
always good to keep the threats up rick
c5 not only did my rook get to a better
square
it hit the bishop and hit it with tempo
give my king in a better square knight
a4
was a fork knight to d7 now we probably
should back up come back home to
civilization
and what should we do now since icaru
may be pushing
maybe that's a strong maybe but maybe
pushing
just to see what happens he boozes
bishop to a5 it's a very surprising move
very surprising move but you get tons of
those from hikaru
like i don't even know what this move
ever does at all i have no idea
basically if i guess it blocks this
it's uh def it's just a weird move
bishop a5 bishop
b4 bishop c5 this is more solid here
more attention to it rick to c3 hitting
the bishop get out of the way
maybe bishop h1 yeah he did that too
bishop h1
no trades keep the clock running on him
knight takes b3 was an option dang angry
twin is strong
like he just keeps swinging at hikaru
bishop f8 there it is
game's over game's over he got caught
with one you know those guys this boxing
he's swinging at him and swinging man
this guy's good
and then he he got caught by his chin
with an uppercut and that's it that's
it this should be over in a few check
bring the rookie in now
there is no checks for black besides
knight takes b3 and queenie two
which uh he might have a perpetual huh
yeah i
understand hikaru i do one now you can
the combos are too much hit him with the
check here
hit him with the check here i guess he
had a perpetual he had a perpetual
knight takes b3 and queen e2 was was
very weird
if you step around it he would check you
if you took the knight he was going to
check you many many times
many many times
okay
nice jobby karu nice combo in the end
see that one more time
yeah didn't work beautiful
absolutely beautiful chest there carl
was putting on a display here
they're just coming in and i'm just
trying to win like that's it i'm just
coming in and i'm just trying to win
like
another day in the office boys nothing
in the office jesse carver
another day in the office
five out of five jostling was playing
really good too
josslyn was playing really good chess
yeah hikaru and uh joshua josslyn's in
first place too
josslyn's like first first i have tie
breaks first
11 out of uh like 11 is this tie break
like
wow eleven point to me
yeah at this level one blunder will
wreck your entire game john guy think
about this
one inaccuracy in the opening not even
losing upon
like you know just wrong move order in
the opening you know
it's over oh that that theory was 1970s
they don't do that anymore
you know it's that kind of level
kingy one white's winning here oh can
you just oh yeah yeah that just works
that works i was thinking rook takes
first for some reason but
bishop c6 just works his pinned take it
and then we're queening anyway
gg brandon jacobson's strong too
i see him play a lot last game here oh
we have a a weird well
actually there's two pawns on the board
so this should be way easier for black
to win if these pawns if all three pawns
were gone guys
this would be very hard for black to win
bishop versus rook bishop and rick king
versus king rook
one of the hardest ones now of course
you can see the person with the bishop
and rook checkmate
but there's a certain certain sequence
of moves to have have that have to
happen
and it does it's not easy it's not easy
a lot of uh
triangulation and like uh maneuvering
and then zoo swing and then like
rook here but then you gotta stop here
but then you gotta check them here and
then you gotta come back to the fourth
ring then go up here then back to the
seventh ring
and then move the bishop it's insane
it's insane it's endeavor rescues
in-game manual
which is uh really really ridiculous
black won that one yeah this one was
easier with the pawn too and of course
no work on the board
and that's the end of round five guys
after five rounds let's see who's
sitting up at the top here
actually itari zaga the terry zaga
from venezuela actually sitting at top
let's take a look at their game so let's
see who's at the top here
brandon jacobson and hikar was right at
the top once again
have you been up to date have oh you
have to be up to date with theory
opening theory is very important to know
yeah brandon jacobson is i am strong
yeah he's uh he's really strong
really strong oh we have a night or
shout out to all the night or fans out
there but actually no this is some type
of dragon like
i see g6 here i saw a6 and d6
immediately thought
then he has an early a6 though in this
which is uh different
you know guys i think carlo has played
the bishop on g7
every single game with black if you guys
notice
every single game with black he's put
the bishop on g7 if you know
that that cuts down a lot of study time
even for me
when i was playing a hyper-accelerated
dragon with black i would put the bishop
on g7 but now with um
d4 i'm able to play king's indian
defense which is
still bishop on g7 what is the best book
for middle game that's a great question
honestly and
it's not many books out there on middle
game but one of the strongest and the
hardest ones is
panchenko's mastering middle games
that's a mastering chess middle game so
that was not a easy
it was not easy at all so other than
that one i don't really know any like
it's hard to find
those
but here i think black has a really
strong position he didn't castle notice
guys
your king your king doesn't have to
castle every single game
a lot of people think that you have to
castle
every single game but that is not true
that is not true at all
you your king actually sometimes is
safer here
because of king side attacks and also
you see what he did here
he shut down all counter play for the g
pawn
if you're playing white here what's your
what do you usually do right
you're gonna push the pawns you're gonna
play the bishop over here and you're
gonna try to mate
but he cut that off and the kings here
in the center looking kind of safe maybe
king to d7
in some cases that looks crazy though
king d7 might be too much to try to
activate the rooks but
we'll see what he does thank you so much
no problem what's up sith what's up
here's a very close pawn structure to
protect the king correct
correct and now we do trades trades
definitely will help black in any
sicilian guys not any but
most sicilians if you think about this
trades will help black
so if you're playing and you don't know
what you're doing maybe you got a
cramped position
and cramped positions even outside the
sicilian trading is generally the rule
here though uh it dude it does help it
does help to
make some trades here for black the
bishops even get to open up towards the
king a little bit
even as queen b8 move it's this very
sneaky move because it also threatens
stuff like b4
maybe a5 a4 first to anchor this pawn at
a3
so when we break with b4 he can't push
past me if we play b4 a4 is kind of
annoying
so he actually moves his queen back to
c7 instead though
keeping pressure here on c2 the idea is
95 knight c4 type stuff
bishop back to e6 weird
that's funny that's funny gory is my guy
too corey's
awesome c3
i still got knight e5 bishop b3 first
okay
then knight a5 there it is
very interesting though you never
believe you're crying
you guys are crazy 95 knight to c4 looks
really good
bishop c42 which one's better is the
question bishop c4 allows knight b3
and if you take it then i have knight c4
anyway he pre-moved that
that was on pre-move he knew he was
going to play e5
and then back to bishop up now knight to
b3 and knight c4 look at the domination
here bishop f5 is coming
man bishops on g7 like what happened
here only a few moves
and now black is just feels like
dominating now bishop f5 seems scary
luckily this bishop covers here because
bishop f5 would end it all
followed by queen to c4 it will be queen
c4 bishop f5 and knight b3 as the combo
but the bishop keeps this from from
happening so
at least he's okay but you see how he's
trying to do it anyway he's trying to
get it in this way
and the knight to b3 same thing
3200 too strong for this field yeah he
got a few that could hang with him
a lot like really hard you know
we got a few but very few what if you
just check now
b3 man that sucks to play b3 but it
might be okay
might be okay or actually you just move
the king back
no the knight check and then takes and
then bishop e6
check here white's just winning now
doesn't it i think it still
works no he has bishop d1 bishop h6 very
strong that's a piece
oh my goodness look at the disconnection
this is gross like oh my
like this is a family channel you know
ikaru man
this is ridiculous bishop takes d2
anyway
okay we gotta show this guys bishop
takes d2 right
bishop takes d2 this was gross take my
rook i don't care your queen's hanging
and your king's hanging your king is
hanging so let's move the queen out of
the way
and then check king here you can't go
anywhere
look at the domination of all the pieces
here beautiful harmony here
you can do literally anything but this
one's mate though
this one's made beautiful
yeah the king was hanging i mean yeah
queen's hanging but your king's
definitely hanging over here
jeez man
big boy chest from the big fella
okay rick b2 he's getting off the
diagonal but you could also take it too
maybe he wants to double take him double
could be a possibility
double pawns aren't that good how did he
get here usually you have double pawns
if you lose one of your knights like
that
but somehow it was a bishop for him it
seems like
that's kind of that's very weird it's a
very weird position like how did you get
this to happen
without losing a knight it's kind of
different
rick p6 knight takes e5 yeah this
doesn't look good too
too good for white i don't like this too
much three six three four five
i'm like down the pawn and i have double
pawns here
doesn't feel good great peace harmony
killer diagonals i know that was
amazing that was absolutely amazing that
was sharp for white yes he had a series
of moves just to stay alive correct
have you studied tarash the game
let me study to wrest the game of chess
at all no i've never actually heard of
that book but i do know um
tarash the player and also the opening
is dynamic very dynamic and underrated
very underrated
fish takes d5 get a pawn at least
oh that's nice though that's nice that's
even better
that's even better check get out the way
i'm good white's fighting
he is fighting living off the increment
here and fighting his way back to
something
be careful don't get made it just
probably walk the king up honestly as
weird as this is oh
engine didn't like that at all it must
have been something like f6 lock him in
like we saw daniel naredichki do
yesterday
to uh timor that was nasty that lock in
that mate was
gross takes rook b7
living off the increment here and now
actually what's his name gwenplan
going plane with the black pieces here
is now right same living off the
increment
it's almost made luckily this is losing
some oh
my goodness hit that man with the move
wow that's mate that is checkmate
check the screen check the screen look
at look at the screen right now
it's made
it's made i didn't think that was made
at all i thought he just was going to
check him
wow did you see that yo
that hurts that definitely hurt
that was a pretty mate i mean you don't
see that often
you don't see that often
family stream you already know come on
now made on the middle of the board i
mean
what a mate that was great
tang bruh that's sweet sweet guys that
was amazing
that was absolutely amazing
let's check out this gm here
living off the increment this is a draw
guys dead draw here
and a draw was offered but declined
decline says no i'm about to flag you i
know you get one second every move
but i'm still gonna flag you is what he
says
here ball and james let's go let's go
what's up ob man this is a draw guys
this is a draw this is probably going to
be the last game
of this round let's see if any other
players
are uh yeah it's one of the last games
now okay they took a draw there it is
there it is okay cool they didn't keep
us here to tomorrow
we're good
oh this is an interesting one
surprisingly you see how the eval bar
says is equal here you would think that
the two ricks would be better but
there's nothing else on the board but
these pieces so that makes a difference
um that's a check step out of the way
another check
oh knight b3 missing 83.
oh he's in trouble oh my goodness he
lost no he didn't okay he found a move
at least
this is a cool game to learn something
from guys
because i don't know what's going to
happen here he wants to play knight f3
king f4
i honestly don't know what's going to
happen oh 50 move rule okay thanks
chess.com appreciate it
that's funny a 50 move rule
okay here we go hikaru and joss bum this
is a big boy game right here
this is a very very strong game guys hey
carl versus josslyn
both of these players of course are
legends
he carried more than josslyn but that's
josephine is known
and if you don't know today you're going
to know he has six games same amount is
he karu
same amount he has to play all the same
players he carved but basically has to
play
but is he they're not hikaru right so
let's see what happens
let's see what happens here so this
opening choice was the bishop's opening
if a favorite of near disney's as well
a3
and blitz games knight to g3 probably
i don't really know the theory behind
this this is some kind of uh
it means feels like a roy feels like a
roy
but it's really not a roy though
again it's the bishop's opening who is
young
karthia kyan murali
queenie two's on the board i'm just not
a big fan of this bishop's opening kind
of setup here i would rather have my
bishop either on a2 or g2 more in the
king's indian attack fashion
if we're gonna have this pawn set up
like this this is usually what you'll
have in the king's indian attack
takes takes and you know we have to play
we have to it's a game
castle we're out of the way here maybe
h3 bishop g4 is quite annoying
there it is h3 and h6 was doing the same
bishop to e6 it actually was stopping
knight g5 because that's annoying
so bishop v6 he's not really going to
take on b3 and give up the bishop here
because it is a slight advantage
bishop to d2 not only does it connect my
rooks but bishop to c3 is an option to
hit the
e5 pawn there it is immediately bishop
d6 would have probably answered with
here
and maybe sacrificing some material
knight to d7
defending e5 very beautiful move here
getting out of the range
knight to d3 f6 probably now to defend
maybe followed by b4
plays bishop d6 instead interesting move
does not want to play f6 so he says
knight h4
i'm gonna take over this f5 square might
try to bring another knight around there
too
works at d1
93 looks bad by the way yeah now and now
it's looking pretty good c5 very strong
move i mean these pawns are extreme
extremely annoying here that's why i
actually
whipped out b4 before because i was like
yeah b4 b4
wow b4 b4
yeah but uh i was going to play b4
before but it was um
it was this because of this like this is
annoying you have to back everything up
now
not the easiest knight c5 c5
b4 there it is takes takes black's the
one pressing a little bit
pip and chuck what's up man how are you
welcome to the stream let's go
can you look at the standings somewhere
standings are actually right under me
guys right under me
if you want to look at them actually
yourself too as well you can actually go
into live chess click on tournaments
into live when you're live chess and
click on the in progress tab
actually there's a link right there
appreciate that from max milneck there
he is
in the chat you can click that link
right there buddy queen of three knight
f5
these pawns got a little bit too far
than what they were supposed to so black
has more space than white does this
knight is gross
but again remember we talked about
getting the knight to f5
so maybe that's the route we might take
at this point but if this knight moves
and rig a2 happens
and then you have problems here on the
back rank and past pawns that are a
little bit further than they should be
so if we play 92 rook a2 could be
immediate maybe bishop c1 in that area
though because this bishop is not doing
anything anymore
so maybe 92 rook a 2 and bishop c1
still playing knight f5 in some cases
even though this pawn's here
there it is 92 if rook to a2 we play
bishop c1
and defend it bishop h4 hitting the
knight that's a great move
that was a really good move g3 yeah this
is how you know it's not that
easy for him anymore bishop takes h4
pawn takes and h5
we could use this h-pawn as a lure but
this pawn's hanging
i told you guys joseph came to play you
know jasmine got the same amount of
points as hikaru
and you know he's pressuring hikaru here
this pawn's hanging
these pawns are doing real good if you
look at the engine the engine is like
you know the car was crushed here
basically but of course you are we're
not playing engines here you know
this there's going to be human moves and
you know this three this minus three
could go to equal
very quickly you'd be surprised
you you would be surprised here so
good evening humans what's up what's up
jackie the alien
what's up man e4 is hanging it was it
was
i can't see really enjoyed commentary
thank you so much kenra
yep i hope you have a great time there
in the us chess qualifiers
we have off day today night to see one
the knights on c1 now rook a1 just doing
a thing back here
i mean look at all of white's pieces
right hikaru is not that happy in this
position
all the pieces are backtracking here we
don't have the real attack but we can
maybe see something like bishop
e3 queen h6 king h2
rook h1 and king g1 sounds ridiculous
but it's a plan
and a bad plan is better than no plan at
all we have seven out of seven
we'll have some oh somebody got seven
out of seven we've got seven
six and a half i see a six and a half
from fair chess
six and a half so far
okay dude was joshua you know what i
forgot his name but i always know him
for my job
like that's how i know him joshua and i
was saying this guy still is so strong
like he's so strong oh here he is jose
eduardo martinez there he is yeah
he's really strong he's always at the
top if you look at the binoculars when
you're playing live chess and you're
watching games
he's like always at the top so from
i will see him play like every day
bishop c4
hitting e2 queen to e1 defending again
this is not the position white wanted
here and as he's starting to feel it
bishop to c5
almost seemed like detrimental but we
could block with the bishop or the
knight as he does so bishop c5 step out
of the way king of g2
and you see this pawn is trying to queen
here the knights are doing a great job
controlling what we can do
but the only thing we're doing right now
is defending this is very bad in
hikaru's situation
reason being is because this is three
minutes one second increment
and they are getting down on time good
thing for hikaru is he's uptime
he's up time so maybe he can swindle
something here
hopefully carl saves this yeah he could
if he fails to do this
josslyn should be winning you see that
the engine just shifted hard there
very hard shift rick d1 was not the move
rookie d1 was not to move but bishop
takes e3
and now it's about even again and even
though it's minus one
human evaluation when you're looking at
the eval bar and you're looking at
humans play
you know this is not lost you see how it
went back to zeros
right it's like oh minus four zeros
minus this is big boy chess right queen
here hitting queen takes f6 queen g7
and he's running out of time yeah this
might be a uh this might be a swindle
this could be a swindle here i feel i
feel the pressure hikaru was putting on
him right now
there it is some that didn't work knight
f6 check
anyway if knight takes queen takes so he
moves out of the way
just take on e4 white is now winning
this game can you believe that
swindle didn't we call it right he's
gonna swindle him somehow
and if you look at the clock here he's
down losing the rook right afterwards
that hurts
that one hurt that one hurt probably
knock everything off the table
at that moment anything in front of me
is now on the floor
after that game yikes
yep that hurts it definitely hurts
but you can't make a mistake on that
even like when you you know
you ever played the computer back in the
day or like you know it's just playing
botsonchest.com and you're like i was
winning i was winning
and they just crush you after you make a
mistake
the small mistakes too right small
mistakes
not something that the human eye that's
why he's half something i don't know the
other half
the human eye won't see all right
and that was a win by prague look at
prague playing
guys bragg's playing i mean they bring
we bring out everyone
like title tuesday goes down everybody's
here darrow look
on his day off on his day off you know
playing playing today
bishop c4 king e5
no fork right it was no fork did you
take c6
i wonder if you could win this to be
honest engine doesn't think so but like
you know i'm playing a human here king
d6 was probably a little bit better
especially in his time issue uh he would
have took a bishop though
see what he gets let's see what he gets
he car was the beast yes
i know i know i know it's always a
pleasure to watch ekaro play
can he do anything about that
wow i have no like not that i've never
seen this but this is
this is pretty cool to watch actually
like can he actually do something about
this
this move doesn't seem like he can right
look at him just moving back and forth
like this hey blunder yeah
i'm trying i'm trying to figure out
there's no tricks i was trying to work
something out but
there's no tricks i was trying to get h5
to work or like sacking and then playing
h5
but it actually just doesn't work
what are you doing what is this
what are we coming to watch today are
you serious this got to be the last game
this has got to be the last game yeah
it's two games left and guess who one of
the games are
i wonder does this oh yeah all he has to
do
that was nice that was nice look at him
play back and forth if anyone steps out
it's like
they call these mind squares wow
how do you oh my goodness oh my goodness
this is a draw by the way it's a draw no
matter what
it's a draw but it's just kind of funny
how that happened
bro what you're holding everybody up
right now
yo and everybody everybody just staring
at him everybody stare at him real quick
you know just stare at him
through the screen
what are you doing here why are you
thinking
installing come on max come on there we
go
oh my goodness somebody get you man
that was round seven round seven let's
take a look at the standings before the
round
starts here round seven and around eight
who do you think
of course who else do you think would be
at the top up here
right look at this
look at this round seven guys
round seven has started let's take a
look
at the games ikaru
and bogdan uh he's playing this again yo
guys if you study nakamura's games
and this helps a lot to cut down on
study time because like for me
i play the kings indian defense against
everything except e4 everything has said
before
so if you're playing d4 c4 b3 knight f3
a4 h4 i'm going to play knight f6 and g6
and most likely
g7 in some king city and fashion and if
you notice every single game played with
black here
he has done this setup g6 and bishop g7
and he does other stuff
but g6 and bishop g7 every single time
it's very easy to study that way when
you just figure out kind of what player
you are i know i love tactics and
i love having a bishop on g7 so it's
nice to watch him play
[Music]
round eight guys round eight is here
when you see the winner this is dallas j
herr always wins
jackie the alien all right well let's go
back
i want to i'm going to see a few moves
here knight takes 95 knight c3 queen f3
queen of six
i don't like trading queens early i am
not a fan
if i don't have to if there's other
things that i can do
and then i'll do those as long as it's
not losing right
but i'm not trying to trade queens
immediately bishop g5 that does hang a
knight
but queen takes f7 was made so
he actually just captures just so you
know guys
knight takes f3 now it's just boring
it's
boring this is boring and nakamura has
two bishops swiping the board so
it's not too boring for him but for
white i'm like i didn't
i didn't like this too much maybe ricky
won
thanks 201 steve's appreciate it 97
i feel like you could do this you you
probably should know this is ikaru
the reason being bishop takes king takes
rook takes i get two pawns
i get a third and i'm hitting the knight
so but that shouldn't be enough i mean
especially playing
cardboard don't jump off the dpn like
don't even do that to yourself
so let's not do that you just play
rookie one
defending the pawn the question is what
does he do with his king castle is not
allowed
d6 might be e5 might be because bishop
takes f3 is a nice little in-between
move that could work
but uh i wonder like this d6 is there
problems
is he scared of this move
i don't know
yeah typically kings always hide in that
castle yes
well hey carl's thinking though this is
a first he doesn't think that much
right doesn't think that much so when
he's thinking that's a problem
you know hey carlos starts thinking you
might be in trouble
you might be in some trouble let's put
standings up
some sevens yeah just two sevens there's
d6 yeah look at this nice grip on e5
a bind here knight to d5 looks pretty
good if knight takes pawn takes and we
will expose the king here
but the king can move maybe f7 or d7 and
we do remove this knight
this is a possibility to capture this
probably not the best though
especially after the check knight d4
follows with knight e6 being annoying
so maybe not capturing but in areas he
goes forward anyway it takes
and knight d496 is a possibility but the
pawn hangs
in between that so if we go knight
before you block the connection of the
rick to the pawn so this actually hangs
leading to another pawn that's actually
hanging and taking away e6 for the night
so yeah this is pretty good because this
is a target so you have to play c4 you
need to free up this root
so c4 is probably has to be played
that's probably the best move
and then you can anchor the pawn so you
can try to get the knight in here
he's thinking a little bit too much a
little bit too much here
even though it's 3-1 you don't have many
moves though actually these are like
weird moves you could make them but
there's 94 anyway so bishop takes here
maybe knight takes b5 maybe he's saying
he can justify it
i don't think that's right i don't think
that works
counseling sensibilities change at all
when you consider castling before the
finch had a bishop
do castle extensibilities change at all
when you consider castling
behind the finchetto bishop uh you well
generally speaking
casting behind the fin shadow bishop is
a good way to you know have
king safety and also be able to attack
to as well so if you canceled over here
this bishop is still strong
but if you give it up then you do have
holes around the king so you have to be
careful
it's a you know a little bit of both
honestly
good question nice how you mr protector
yeah petey hemps thank you so much for
that
whoa what happened wait wait wait wait
something that boy
shot up white was winning all right lots
oh rookie seven oh my goodness he
blunted rookie seven
he covered blunder rook e7 missed it
and then it would name me in this line
right here hey carl's actually down a
piece right now
rookie 7 was game over that was lights
out not gonna drop the whole
piece whole thing go oh thank god naka
craig angry commentary appreciate it no
problem show jimbo thank you so much bro
welcome to the stream
carl's good at blitz he's good at
everything he's good at everything
question is how and do we get this
knight is it this way
23 seconds you need to move a little bit
faster here i mean i guess this
it's easier said than done you are
you're up a piece here you feel like
you're winning you're playing in car
rule
right so i guess he's going to give it
back here
knight e8s oh he's just getting this
pawn
makes sense bishop d4
h4 that was gross that was gross
like you had the other way to go and now
you have to like give him this counter
play
h3g4 h3g4
okay
they should d8 oh yeah he's missing all
the moves like bishop
missing everything but his nine seconds
and this three minutes one second
increment here and carl lives right here
i mean this is
and hicario has a lot of time to be
honest in his eyes now this hanging
king goes back draws looking in game
very dry it's looking in game here but
he cargo doesn't draw
nothing he doesn't care about a draw
that's not what he does three minutes
one second increment
he's going he's gonna push i guarantee
you i guarantee you hikaru's not gonna
take a draw
i can guarantee that to you
and even with 29.85 even though the
man's rating is 29.85
hit carl loses like 10 points he lose 10
points
if he if he draws his game he lose like
six points
all right which is still a win it's like
a oh man that's a nice win six points
cool
drew the game interesting he's
sacrificed here
yeah he couldn't figure it out they
couldn't figure it out so this is going
to end in the draw
and not a draw because he wanted one
more because it was like forced
yeah he didn't want to draw at all look
at that you see what he did
yeah i got a draw with a 2900 i lost
five points
right that never comes out of your mouth
unless you're in carburetor nakamura
here's uh oh they both well seven and
seven seven and a half they were both
the top dogs so they both got seven and
a half there
see if any games are left guys
yeah we got some games left mom and me i
know right
we have prague here prague
and fair chess youtube pranks playing
white
playing black draw another draw
good game guys good game great chess
here
white is mating there it is
easy mate walk in somebody get mated
all games should be ending soon this
one's a draw
shuffle back and forth wow
you wanted to win that bad you ever been
there before
you know that's that's a tough one
that doesn't work you just take it and
defend upon so oh yes it's still a draw
i guess it's the draw technically you
never have to move the king
yeah technically that's still a draw are
you able to push this
oh that was sweet hold up hold up
now you can't get to him he can't get to
him there's not enough moves
yeah there's no entry squares like
there's no way to enter
anything that's why it's still a draw
java doing well
yep there we go there's a draw there he
sacrificed spawn still got to draw a
strong game
there whoa oh man he flagged you rarely
see that
you rarely see flagging in three one
three minute one second increment that
kind of sucks there
there's made on the back rank there it
is
make it very easy here and this right
here guys
is the final game and this is another
draw another classic position guys we
talked about this before and there's a
stalemate and there it is still made it
still made it that's round eight let's
take a look at the standings really
quickly
really quickly bogged in actually on tie
breaks got a
one like literally just by one point on
tie breaks so far
it's like crazy but as you see here
seven and a half seven and a half we got
some sevens in here
and i mean these guys are pushing tight
guys it's gonna be awesome here
but uh round nine is gonna be starting
soon guys so round that's gonna be
starting soon but we're gonna take a
quick break so don't go anywhere
enjoy it guys good to see you in the
chat and we'll be back in a few
[Music]
please
please show us your sorcery once more
prefer maiden
guys how many times do i have to tell
you it's not sorcery it's on juno
the mystical slab of divine
enlightenment your king holds the wealth
of the land that you work so hard to
harvest
that you get so little in return with
onjuno you can get more on your deposits
i have no idea what any of that means
your king is greedy
he could let you earn more but he
doesn't believe you have a choice
yeah we want more coin we want more
coins
we want more coin perfect i think you
guys are starting to get it
yes it is here's the witch oh i don't
think they like me
not only do the big banks hoe is the
only interest you could build with your
deposits they also crash you with absurd
fees that net them billions of dollars
every year
oh shut up you can't you don't know what
you're doing if you do this it'll spread
a curse across all the line my lord she
showed us the light
she's a witch
as a digital banking platform on juno
keeps its costs low
there are no hidden fees no minimum
bounce fees and no worries
i don't respect what you're saying
because it's new and different and it
scares me and if you want to send your
money around the globe soon you'll be
able to at a great price with no hassle
the world is flat
the world is flat right yes
for sure which way
and who doesn't love getting cash back
on their favorite brands
i do love my cash back okay
you're a queen now oh wow thank you
[Music]
our rain has just begun make the switch
to anjuno
[Music]
what's going on guys we're back we're
back we're back round nine has started
let's go hikaru is in the ring he's up
in first place with bogdan who's
actually tied actually no bogdan has
first off
tie breaks and carl is actually second
but he has the same amount of points
with seven and a half
so let's actually pull the game up guys
let's get right into it here we go
uh there it is okay so here's the game
that's what we got so
far his his signature stuff would be
three
the usual right signature stuff there's
a standings right there
so there's a queen on c8 it's almost
like he started like this in 960 fashion
kind of weird kind of a weird setup
he moved the queen to c8 then he moved
the rick to d8 but i think he's prepping
guys for this d5 push if you see this
like
x right here always be aware of the
x-rays what they say
always be aware of the x-ray so richard
d8 is on the board as we have icaru
thinking about this one
let's see well e4 actually fails tonight
takes d4 so actually plays knight to c2
instead interesting gets the knight out
of the way
now he can play knight e4 and knight to
e3 to take over the d5 square
if he ever tries to play e6 and e6
actually leaves a hole on d6
allowing knight b5 knight to d6 95
good move just trading because i have
less space if you have less space you
look for trades
and white has less space or black has
less space so he wanted to trade there
and he does he's he's successful in that
attempt now queen to b7 the queen
has now can help connect the rooks
knight has to go somewhere
knight g4 loses the knight actually
after h3
this pawn is actually defended so you
have to go back knight c6
rook be one on pre-move basically
defending the bishop some of the best
players in the world
the best attacking players always make
sure the pieces are defended before
doing anything else
and the pieces here is defended the
bishops nicely defended
against any type of attacks or anything
that can happen in the future
pretty pretty different
how many total players are in a
tournament we have a 515 players
how are some enemies higher rated than
gm's uh because they
you know you just get stronger and when
you get stronger it shows in your game
and your rating
so a lot of people are underrated
especially in this year you know
people have been studying not able to
play in tournaments it's going to be a
lot of un
underrated players coming through so be
careful what section you win
when you go play on your over to board
tournaments be careful on what section
you're playing in take every game
serious because you don't know what they
did in the off time
queen to e2 e45 knight b 596
it white has a very nice grip on the on
everything i think this might have to be
played
because e4 is a very strong move this is
very strong so maybe
can you get away with d5 takes yeah you
could you could play d5 the intention is
just stopping the e4 square
from having any type of action because
it has a lot of action right now
e4 can be very strong followed by
something like f5 or e5
if e4 and e5 you go knight e4 knight d6
and all the pieces just get annoying
there it is d5 is on the board he
pre-moved captures actually
takes and now he's taking over the e4
square that we wanted so bad
now rick to d1 attacking the pawn so
either or we would have been able to
play e4
but we're going to bully this pawn one
or the other and he chose
well i'm just not going to give you the
square so you're going to have to bully
my pawn
and that's what he's doing maybe queen
f3 we could see next to see if this
works
there it is queen f3
queen f3 cardigan title and there's so
many few live tournaments yeah
all the titles are based on classical
rating and norms that is right
that is right queens on f3 though queens
on f3 this pawn is hanging you have a
choice to make do we play knight e4 but
that just hangs
um yeah d4 i was about to say that and
let them just capture and then we
capture this pawn and
our our bank we're banking on us to
to find some type of counter play around
around this pawn
it's black if i'm playing black here i
need to figure out can i win this pawn
back
because white's now up a pawn
isolated correct this isolated true true
queen true
the true king with the q yeah it's
definitely uh
isolated definitely i said it so that's
that's the plan we have to bully the
isolated pawn like we talked about
earlier today too is like pile the
pieces on it
try to control the square in front of
the pawn so moves like knight d6 and
knight f5
jump into mine he's actually giving it
back right now
he gave it back right now oh did he have
to
let's go back he might have had to
after a5 so does knight c2 do no good
you in trouble on ic2
apparently i guess he didn't like knight
c2 maybe b5 or something
so he had to give it back in the way
what up james do you ever play in t in
title tuesday i actually play
entitled tuesday i my best score was six
points
six points it was six or six and a half
which is nice we're all
psyched let's go eleven rounds you know
let's go i took some else to some big
fellas but
i did i took down some big fellas as
well so i had six out of eleven it was
pretty nice this was uh last year my
last title tuesday
but i do like commentating them and
watching
and just like when they're on it's like
awesome bro title tuesday is
this you get your you get some real play
against the big boys
everybody you're playing is titled so
you can't you know sometimes you just
can't pass that up
that was very nice tactics here b7 is
hanging
whoa there is a lot of checks lots of
stuff going on here
maybe not lots of checks but there's a
check down here this knight's hanging
looks everywhere to very deceiving
though this might not be that bad it's
actually
zeros as you see the engine is like
slightly better for this person but
i believe it is zeros as well there is
no mate surprisingly guys
no mate king g2 and um i can sidestep
and go king h3
and keep my threats alive myself very
nice move he plays knight to d6 make
some trades you got to be careful where
you put your king
king f2 with no checks there's a capture
two seconds on the clock man he's not
he's not gonna make this he living off
the increment
he's living off the increment here
living off the increment
king f5 king g5 there's a4 actually rick
b2 ring b7
and king g5 kg6 yeah this this could be
over
canty thanks bro
appreciate that appreciate that yeah so
one second on the clock as we go back
and forth here
check there's another check come on now
come on now what are we gonna
wait was the bishop no but both bishops
were hanging here both bishops were
hanging he's living off the anchorman
you know that one second
is he's surviving off one second here
somehow some way
it's so scary because when you got two
seconds you got to make moves really
really fast here and you can't pre-move
wrong or you know you just lose in that
manner
but he's down two pawns now so white's
just gonna win this one pick it off here
there it is there's the piece now
this should take safe oh not do that
let's not do that
and he flags any flags because the
game's over
anyway gg so i'm good this is round nine
guys
round nine uh here we go oh parent
versus bogdan
this one yup draw draw i don't
ever have to move anything he was also
down a piece as well so there's a draw
nice game there that one ended in a draw
folks
young kid wow whoa
wow look at this mate oh my goodness
look at this mates you see that
there's two queens on the board he let
him
he let him queen i'm assuming he let him
queen let's see how this happened
he cleaned check it was forced
it was forced oh my goodness
how did this happen again check it was
forced
wow man that was beautiful
not every day did you see mates like
that
yeah this one's a tough one too can you
can you shelter the king
it'd probably just go back and forth oh
he let you take the pawn king takes f4
king e5 that's a lot of checks
a lot of checks here ideally you wanted
to go oh he couldn't play knight e5
yeah you want to get the rook back here
and play and get the knight on f7
and mate on h8 that's the whole idea
here looks like they're going to take a
draw maybe though
ricky won yeah he's not doing it
he's strong enough to know that's the
idea though like rick here
yeah he's just moving he doesn't even
care to put the rig down there
now the king gets out man that was like
sweet bro put the rook there and always
try to get the knight to f7 as quickly
as possible
another king's out
tough game now i think black could win
this now king's getting too close
king's getting way too close
oh my goodness oh my goodness
jasper with the nasty mate
wow look at this mate y'all
look at this mate there is this is like
the the day of the mates okay good day
mate good day mate
right that's that's great that is
excellent there wow
yeah what you're supposed to do is
actually keep the work
down here so like work down here you
know and then like i don't know
check you can check me again
but the idea though is to get this
knight to f7
if i get the knight to f7 it's made it
easier said than done
and i also could like go here too that's
a check to look forward to
you know it was a good plan even in time
trouble
that was a beautiful uh game though
round 10 is starting guys round 10 is
starting
and here are two fan favorites we have
min lee look at him with eight
eight points right behind hikaru
right behind icaru with half a point you
know it's only a matter of time for
where he just says gm by his name nasty
this is a family channel that's right
man come on
g day mate you know grizzly foot
come on now that was beautiful can't you
put in work lately you already know
elephant bush
just his life life is chess bro queen d2
defending b2 what happened let's
actually see this out of the opening
okay so you know hikaru with min lee
they play actually quite
often so you won't see probably the
regular stuff
you won't see probably the regular stuff
actually yeah let's get some updated
scores here here we go guys updated
scores eight and a half for
karu and eight for dang
joe bava chobava going off too look at
him eight out of nine
jaba came out of nowhere bogdan with
eight out of nine
uh min lee with eight out of nine parham
eight out of nine i'm not sure who this
one is the jurabek
yourself though big boy chess today
bishop g4 hitting
f3 knights question is what do we do
bishop b2 knight d2 queen
i think the queen and i know the queen
feels extremely misplaced on d2
like how do you develop your knight do
you go to a3 but you can't go back to c2
so i don't know about this game for men
lee right now black actually has a very
excellent position bishop outside the
pawn chain okay
usually if it's locked in it's more like
french type structures and this is a
french type structure but this is like a
good french
if anyone if you think about the french
defense this is a very good french and
somebody says london in the chat this
looks like a bad london right
with the queen on d2 somehow you got a
very bad london system
with white but with black somehow you
got a very good french because in the
french the bishop's usually bad but
instead it's actually outside the pawn
chain
and the queen putting pressure exerting
pressure on the center as well
some type of good french
black's doing good usually in this type
of position blacks black looks to play
very solid
trades and end games not afraid of end
games at all james who are you rooting
for oh absolutely hikaru gar was a beast
man this is great
watching car will play i'm not a fan of
in particular this setup of course he's
going for but i'm a fan of fincado with
my bishop on g7
i love the hyper accelerated dragon i
played that for like five years
and then uh now i'm kid for life kings
indian defense so
bishops on g7 i'm a fan of them big fan
of a bishop on g7
lots of experience with that so when he
plays it i'm like watching the entire
game trying to pick something up what is
he doing here
because you get to learn you get to
learn when you're watching car or you
should try to learn
when you're watching hikaru or any
strong player and see what you can take
from it
pawn takes in b4 looks pretty good a3 b4
he actually just takes and gets rid of
it knight b3 said i'm going to the d4
square that's where i'm headed
knight f3 knight b3 same thing and he
plays here i'm headed for the c4 square
to attack your pawns and if you push him
it makes him kind of weak and he plays
brick b1 instead
put the knight back on d6 maybe playing
e5
maybe black has a great position though
more like a carol khan type structure
here scandinavian type positions
great structure
it's funny what do you play versus e4
dragon because no k
id yeah i used to play a little bit of
modern actually but
um i play uh i play an accelerated
stretch took off i'm just going to leave
it there
and accelerate it stretching the cough
that's all i'm going to say
that's all i'm going to say it's my
favorite opening right now it's e4
he says something how long about yeah
the uh accelerated dragon
the accelerated dragon was with hyperx
other dragon was really fun to play
so b5 oops queen d4
takes which way are we taking rick takes
he says keep it open
black's doing everything in their power
they're doing everything they're
supposed to do with the black pieces
here get the bishop outside the pawn
chain
trade the bishop and then go into an end
game and play on the queen side
also check this guys your pawn structure
tells you where you should play
and your pawn structure pointing this
way which means you're usually strongest
on this side of the board where hikaru
is playing at strategically
mastering doing great no problems here
but it does take time it does take time
and these are slow positions
not my cup of tea i'm an attacking
aggressive player i love towel
type positions sacking mating and
gambits
my kind of stuff you know my favorite
kind of chest is
a gambit that has been hit thoroughly
with the engine
and looked through and combed through
very finely
that's how that's why i came up with the
c3 cecil for the keel it's very nice
different than the regular c3 cecilia
canty plays the jar jar gambit we might
we might make up one
that'd be funny i'll make up something
g5 takes takes
knight f3 probably uh he plays rick h4
nice move playing for rick h1
rick hey maybe one of the force moves
he plays knight f7 instead because if i
check you if you do get this check
you can't do anything further than just
checking me because i have the h8 square
cover by the knight
b4 is now a possibility plays e5 look at
this pawn mass
beautiful sensor for black here even
though it's zeros as a human looking at
this
this is definitely not zeros
definitely not zeros
h4 early on you play h5 anyway pip and
chuck you can play h5 early if they do
that
you can page fine
evil d4 e4 it happens it will happen
mean it'd be okay though just just work
on your game every day
and not analyze your games look at stuff
look at grand master games i think he
had e4 in there
but that just yeah these pawns are too
strong anyway so probably not
these pawns are extremely strong black
is gonna be the one pushing for more but
it is zeros right here as you see he's
just kind of making moves moving back
and forth
trying to figure out whatever he can
pawn structure while it is right
white's pawn structure structure's
garbage but i mean and not even garbage
it's just this one's weak
and these are but this one's weak you
know it's kind of weird
a4 can freeze all these two pawns so
it's different different but it is zeros
i mean it's been zeros for a while here
hikaru may not be able to take another
draw i mean he can
if he wants to but how does that hurt
him in the standings
this is the standings right now yeah and
he cargo has what eight and a half
and he draw that would that would that
would put him in first or that would
be a tie for first nine points parham
and joe baba
are both with nine points guys nine out
of ten i mean jeez
9 out of 10 in this field come on
have you ever tried disgust gaming i'm
playing it and i love it absolutely i
got a youtube
series i have like five i don't know how
many videos i probably got more than
five i think like 10 videos
on my youtube channel about the scotch
gambit
absolutely
rook d8 takes 95 94.
oh this nice been playing min i mean you
you expect that from in any
anyway but min is playing right now you
can't move the rook i mean tonight
actually you can he could play king g5
so he calculates so fast the something
it's just really unfair sometimes that
hikaru calculates so fast and now he's
losing
completely lost after that move
completely lost
wow
you just have to laugh at this it hurts
it hurts to see sometimes
it does it hurts playing so good playing
so well
and then just saw the building and
jumped off it
like uh they hurts that hurts z kid in
fair chess
that's uh zertz i think that's steven
ooh oh no this nice defending f2 for
some reason
we thought mate was there yeah that hurt
that hurt canty cargo fan boy absolutely
everybody should be a car with him but
at least of the game you know you have
to realize
his game is just solid and
if he plays what you play and carl plays
the um
he plays kings inn in defense and uh he
came to detroit actually i'm here in
michigan
and he had a simul here and i had dinner
with him so it was pretty cool to hang
out with him
uh yeah i mean knight at four just check
and go back to e2 bro
don't make this too hard
somebody's gonna blunder somebody's
gonna blunder
at this rate somebody's gonna blunder
they are not trying to draw this game
and there it is there it is something
happened there's a pawn
gave a pawn up oh he couldn't take on g6
let's see if he takes
takes takes okay this is a draw draw
like a draw for real draw
like a for real for real draw
there we go there we go there we go
there we go perfect that's a draw
i'll have a sitting here all day waiting
on that game this one right here though
yeah this is a draw too as soon as you
move the rook this is more of a fill the
door type position doing great here
yeah he's doing great he has all the
space he needs to check
you can't create a bridge you can't
block with the brook
he just keeps checking them very good
very good technique there
that was good technique and this is the
last game here and this one's another
draw here all we got
all we do is shuffle here all we do is
shuffle
okay you covered the guy in first place
yeah all you do is shuffle there
you guys it's a draw it's a draw
it's a draw here let's see how long we
sit here well it takes 50 moves right
50 move rule and you know you have to
thank chess.com
everyone just staying chess.com okay you
know
claps and all that other good stuff
because uh if it wasn't for the 50 move
rule
if it wasn't for the 50 move rule they
would probably get up to like
you know two hours on time because you
got one second increment pre-move it and
keep pre-moving
and keep moving until you get all this
time where you can just sit and think
and do nothing until somebody takes a
draw if they even want to take one
and there it is they took a draw it was
like all right cool everybody's watching
our game now
because we're at the last game let's
just end this
and that was around 10 guys let's take a
look at the standings we got one more
round here
and he karu is still in first place nine
and a half the only one
running away with the whole tournament
with a half a point more guys
half a point more well let's check out
the final game here we definitely have
to check this out
hey carlo versus parham here very strong
play and we are going to see
the roy lopez berlin actually let's see
if we get a berlin
and if we do we probably gonna go to
sleep right here right now
everybody just go to sleep
wake up when the game's over and there's
a castle there
rookie one d4 perfect not the boring
boring stuff not the boring boring stuff
more of the aggressive stuff
i think he says that come that's right
man berlin is a resident sleeper yep oh
absolutely
come on now
go to sleep everybody that's it that's
how they gonna do us
that's how they gonna do us right that's
how they gonna do us right here
they're gonna hit us with the berlin and
just take a draw
that's how they did this right here man
they really did this like this
i know i know right i know it was a draw
you drew a 20 moves last i know
you want that draw so quick oh man
boring was smart yeah if you see right
here you got 10 out of 11. so
i mean that's going to actually shoot
nine and a half out of 11
10 out of 11. so he clears first i mean
there's nobody that can catch
him that's why he took it can't fall
guarantee money yet he actually gets
like first first like or he's maybe tie
breaks he might be somewhere else off
tie breaks but
i mean 10 points is is the top score 10
out of 11.
no losses he took two draws i mean
amazing chess
amazing chess well let's look at uh
something else then
other games
i mean i really wanted to see uh some
something else there and i was excited
to watch this and then they was like oh
yeah draw bro
what what you mean draw
it's okay though it's guaranteed money
okay the ad lasts longer than the draw
did
funny game that was a funny queen e2 and
then i'm down in exchange i knew i was
like do something look wrong
joe bava here did he like sacrifice this
exchange or like
he lost this exchange let's look at
compensation did he get anything for it
three pawns
three pawns six pawns and five pawns so
he got a pawn for the exchange
and maybe a bishop i mean a nice slight
square bishop
where he's bad on light squares his king
can go to dark squares which we kind of
have
kind of have covered with the queen here
it doesn't seem like enough compensation
but
engine thinks that it's about equal it's
about
equal depends on tie breaker wins if
jabal wins yes
that's right that's right that is
correct
can't take the knight and e5 you found
pawn
well you know what that was an idea that
is an idea
and there's an idea you have to be
careful with that though the more that
comes off
like the heart the harder it is for you
to really
create some kind of counter play you
don't want to get to a position where
you have a night versus work that would
be
disastrous you have to be careful with
the material you do
choose to do to give up queen e2 may be
going back
bishop g4 is a move isn't it
bishop e4 is one too
yeah you want bishop before hard
position i mean i'm down some material
so ricky five it's going to be hard
maybe king h1 to try to play f4
and if rook here bishop d5 you play g3
king g2 is the intention i'm assuming
maybe moving to bishop but i think king
g2 is what he wants to do
play f4
king g7 getting off the light squares
there it is king to g2 because you
wanted to
step out of the pin now we can play f4
it's a risky move
but this rook is very short on spaces he
plays knight d2
knight c4 is the intention here
forking the queen in the row again the
rook is very short on spaces here
f4 rookie six now he plays knight f3
instead hitting
the rook black is starting to close in
on this position
unless she flags him no way jabba wins
unless he flags him no way joe baba wins
this when he says
you know i mean hey i think it's
double edged i'll say that it's double
edged because he does have a chance deal
but it's a hard position with that
inquiry that require
requires like it really requires there's
no
in between it requires you to be precise
here
don't give up anything and play the best
moves you can possibly find
because you're down in exchange a whole
exchange here
this isn't any playing 2966 rated here
gm here with eight and a half points
well no he has nine job has nine you
know how good he is
but still oh yikes that was a
sweet move guys did you see that oh my
goodness that was beautiful and then he
takes on b4
dang that was sweet and he could play
bishop before and then bishop takes b7
is the idea hit the rook
get this pawn and try to queen still got
some comp
yeah that was sweet bro knight before
it i mean like that tactics win games
until suda says all the time
tactics win games that was a beautiful
tactic now he liquidated and remember
what we talked about
you don't want to trade as much because
you don't want to get down to a position
whereas bishop and rook
versus your pieces if you want to at
least keep the rook on
try to snag a few more pawns and then
you might be okay trading the bishop
now this is beautiful so far i wonder if
he could push it anyway
you go what if you just push the pawn
what is it i don't think there's no
issues king e8 then rick c7
king yeah rick c7 king d8 oh you can't
take on e7 huh
yeah that wouldn't work okay b3
now he can't push he's making it very
hard for him this was a very nice move
intending stuff like work to b4 even
trying to get my rook
to the seventh rank or second rank
capture this one and queen before you do
black's actually closer to queen and
then white is
black's actually uh better than what it
is
tell me how it's puzzle rush kicking
yeah can i buy my hat from can you buy
it
oh this hat that's not a movie you can
get it from my channel this uh this is
my channel
my twitch channel it's under the march
thing
yeah like he did exactly that right he's
trying to queen before
oh wait a second wait a second
that was nice joe bava pushing tight
look at joe bob out here swinging oh
that was a good move too if you queen i
just take it i mean good move after good
move guys
they have came to play today big boy
chess in every area
he takes it he just says all right cool
whatever
whatever right so now he got the
exchange back oh he can't go there yeah
bishop a2 though here's this one
bishop a2 helps him you can't he can
just go bishop
too yeah there you go bishop a2 you he
could try to
diverge like you know get him off but
that's not going to work takes takes and
now look at joe bible coming back to
draw the game with nine and a half
he's going to be right under hikaru
great job that was excellent
the e-ball bar yeah apparently the right
work before
joe obama has something there yeah it's
tough especially oh wait a second
we're looking for mate threats
has he made it he's it feels like he's
close to made it
kingji no can you do that work okay
wow wow man job is not getting a break
here bro
he just can't get a break man i mean
this is still a draw
this is still a draw guys but now you
have to be even more technical here
this is still a draw watch the technique
you can even take this there it is and
in opposition
in front of the pawn straight back
straight back opposition in front of the
pawn
straight back opposition
in front of the pawn straight back
straight up back
opposition in front of the pawn and
there you go
every time every time and they gotta
draw
that's a draw there is there any more
games
mini
um maybe black wins
yeah maybe black wins guess the move 100
you already know
knockout was sweating there java hat no
that wasn't oh you man yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know for the prize money maybe
splitting it
oh he lost that dang he lost that yeah
well yeah yeah we knew black was winning
though
he had this and then the knight f4 ends
it seals the deal you can't stop all the
pawns
cool we got a few more games here here's
our parent oh we got another
draw another draw here
i feel a swindle coming though nope okay
not
maybe it's not this game man
this is a draw this is a draw you see a
zeros it and now let's say this it's
supposed to be a draw
okay so let's watch
let's watch it's supposed to be a draw
guys there it is
50 move rule okay thanks chess.com once
again
oh wow oh let's get this off the screen
right now let's get this off the screen
i'm sorry oh my goodness this one right
here
another draw how do you get two king and
knight games like this
like king knight rook versus rook i
wonder if they hit the 50 moves oh
they're getting close
they're getting close they're at move
116 now
theoretically yeah sounds like a
basketball drill
straight back opposition that was funny
sounds like a basketball drill
all right guys and that is title tuesday
title tuesday another tuesday double the
prices here guys check it check out the
winners here
of title tuesday you can check the final
scores there on the side guys
pretty awesome um yeah carl
congratulations to ikaru
and joe baba second place all the way
down
uh third place as well guys but we also
have some other prizes
just so you guys can check here if you
see first place 750
seven second place is 600 third place is
fourth place is four all the way down
through seventh place a hundred dollars
there
then you have the highest finished
female highest rated finished female or
highest
placed second highest finished female
and the best streamer whoever streamed
it guys
that's going to be fun too man so this
again was the format if you guys missed
it it was 11 rounds today three minutes
one second increment
and we're gonna have it every single
tuesday here every single tuesday here
at title tuesday guys so um we enjoyed
it i hope you guys have a good one
stick around for the raid we should be
rating someone guys and i will see you
guys on
the next one
[Music]
please show us your sorcery once more
prefer maiden
guys how many times do i have to tell
you it's not sorcery it's on juno
the mystical slab of divine
enlightenment your king holds the wealth
of the land that you work
so hard to harvest that you get so
little in return
with on juno you can get more on your
deposits i have no idea what any of that
means
your king is greedy he could let you
earn more but he doesn't believe you
have a choice
yeah we want more coin we want more
coins
we want more coin perfect i think you
guys are starting to get it
yes it is the witch oh i don't think
they like me
not only do the big banks hoe is the
only interest you could build with your
deposits they also crash you with absurd
fees that nest in billions of dollars
every year
oh shut up you don't know what you're
doing
we didn't spread the curse across all
the land my lord she showed us the light
she's a witch wish
as a digital banking platform on juno
keeps its costs low
there are no hidden fees no minimum
bounce fees and no worries
i don't respect what you're saying
because it's new and different and it
scares me
and if you want to send your money
around the globe soon you'll be able to
at a great price with no hassle the
world is flat
the world is flat right yes uh
for sure which way which will show so
rich
and who doesn't love getting cash back
on their favorite brands
i do love my cash back okay
you're a queen now oh wow thank you
[Music]
our rain has just begun make the switch
to anjuno
[Music]
you